let me pull up this post here from Luke
zaleski every single person
pretending this animal doesn't want to
be a dictator and isn't a clear and
present danger to America and the world
or ignoring the threat of all Americans
my plan to dis all Americans are facing
but only some are actually fighting well
here's Donald Trump ladies and gentl
manle the Deep State and we claim our
democracy from Washington corruption
once and for all and Corruption it is
first I will immediately reissue my 20
20 Executive Order restoring the
president's authority to remove Rogue
bureaucrats and I will wield that power
very aggressively second we will clean
out all of the corrupt actors in our
national security and intelligence
apparatus and there are plenty of them
the Departments and agencies that have
been weaponized will be completely
overhauled so that faceless bureaucrats
will never again be able to Target and
persecute conservatives Christians or
the left's political enemies which
they're doing now at a level that nobody
can believe even
possible third we will totally reform
fisa courts which are so corrupt that
the judges seemingly do not care when
they are lied to in warrant applications
so many judges have seen so many
applications that they know were wrong
or at least they must have known they do
nothing about it they're lied to Fourth
to expose the hoaxes of abuses of power
that have been tearing our country apart
we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission to declassify
and publish all documents on deep State
spying censorship and Corruption and
there are plenty of them so I I don't
want to play the whole thing but I want
to make this point the view of the woke
left the establishment shills is that
Donald Trump's efforts to weaken the
government are fascistic evil
dictatorial Must Be Stopped I didn't
hear anything particularly objectionable
in in what he said other than Truth and
Reconciliation commissions which I'm not
usually for but you know well I think
the Warren Commission you I'm absolutely
for Truth and Reconciliation to go
through the Russia gate hoax all of that
stuff I mean it's normally like Canada
New Zealand you know these are where the
truth I think people don't fully
understand what they're doing there's a
reason this comes from more than just
some idiot Luke whatever his stupid name
is on online this stuff comes from the
highest levels of the Democrat Party On
Down Trump's a fascist he's a dictator
he's going to arrest people he's going
to do this he's a fascist he's a fascist
there's a reason they're saying this and
it's not only to win elections this is
what communist do that's the bad guy
that's the bad guy that's the bad guy
that's the bad guy oh look I have to
hurt him I have no other choice I've got
to arrest him I guess I've just got to
arrest him and throw him in prison look
I had no choice I had to stop the
fascist Stalin did this when Stalin was
busy killing everybody in the great
Terror he wasn't doing it like I'm a
dictator smashing smashing the little
guy he told everyone in the Soviet Union
over and over and over again hey these
are sabur these people are the ones with
the real power they're trying to tear us
down I have no choice but to step in and
stop them I am I am the little guy here
the guy with all the power calling the
other guy a threat to the country almost
always ends call they're calling Donald
Trump a threat to the country and he is
not in any position of authority at all
there's a reason they're doing that
there's a reason they're doing that and
it's not a good one yeah it's like I
said earlier they're going to find that
person to make their enemy which is
Trump which is which is Maga and say
okay those people your enemy and they're
going to be riled up like this and it's
it's I don't know to say nothing of the
signal it sends to their Street Animal
base remember do do we need do we need
to remember that somebody flew from
California with the intention and the
Weaponry to assassinate one of our
Supreme Court Justices he wanted to kill
Brett Kavanaugh and by the grace of God
his he called his sister and his sister
Ste he might have he might have pulled
it off but this is what they do they get
up and they tell people that's the devil
that's the devil that's the devil that's
the devil because they know some nut job
with nothing to live for drugged out of
his mind as you just pointed out
eventually he's going to act on
something like that these people they
Stoke these things over and over and
that's why look it's not let's let's not
act like the next person who gets hurt
on the right is going to be the first
one they've been doing this over and
over again I mean it's it's not just
about it's not about whether or not they
will act there have been Act attacks
like Steve scal still has a
bag because he got shot remember the me
guy who they killed in Portland shot him
in the head you know like I think Michel
rhin it is we we are currently in a
situation where the left had where
people with the left perspective have
broken the law committed murder
committed acts of violence and the
government continues to look the other
way we live in the logic of Herbert Mark
Hughes repressive tolerance that guy set
the whole whole the whole uh the the
tone of how how the left and the right
are going to interact he set it out for
for an entire generation of people and
it essentially boils down to it is okay
to oppress the right because they are
the right that's it that's the only
reason yeah and and so now that's the
logic that we live in people don't even
acknowledge that they are that there are
people that are on the right that have
been Mal treated by the government that
have been targeted by the government
that have been murdered by people that
the government looks the other way they
just and they they don't even
acknowledge these things have happen
worse they dehumanized them of course
they do yeah that's it's nuts man
remember that dude in Utah he was
putting up a bunch of stupid things on
social media about sniper rifle and this
okay but this is a 70 some year old fat
old man who walked around with a cane
who cared for his blind son that anybody
in law enforcement will tell you a guy
with that kind of physical disability
can be arrested peace a thousand
different ways with no chance of
violence you get him when he's going to
get the mail when he's taking the dog
out to pee what did they do they waited
until Joe Biden was coming to town and
the FBI kicked in his door at 2 a.m. and
gunned him down like a dog and they
won't release the body cam footage
that's the Federal Bureau of
Investigation that's where we are yeah I
don't really trust anyone in power when
I was a kid my dad said to me once um uh
if somebody's running for president
that's how you know they probably
shouldn't be president yeah
it's kind of like what happened to
question authority like these leftist
principles that we used to have and now
they're like prop up Authority you know
or like you always say rage on behalf of
the machine you know it's just uh gosh
that's so sad what happened to them you
know it happened to a lot of them I've
described it as as I've described it as
what's called an ant Mill uh uh or The
Circle of Death MH this is where ants
because they follow phone Trails okay
start going in a circle and then they
all follow each other until they
eventually just die of starvation mhm we
CLI that the other day that was a good
clip yeah and so that's what I see right
now with people like him he's not saying
anything this guy Luke he's not he's not
saying anything of Merit another example
is uh Charlie Kirk made a comment about
how diversity racist tiring practices
will result in people looking at you
know a pilot and then making racist
assumptions or assumptions based on race
and uh the cste called him a racist for
doing so and I said calling Charlie Kirk
a racist answers no questions to his
argument makes no argument addresses no
philosophy or moral uh uh philosophies
it quite literally is just an anill the
kste are just saying that because the
person behind them wants to hear it and
then the person in front of them is
saying the same thing and they're all
just in one big circle until they
eventually starve to death and die the
reason why a civil war would be bad is
because so long as the left is on the
path of sterilizing their children
aborting their children and chasing each
other's uh uh refu they will cease to
exist but getting into will fight with
them will just shatter everything so as
long as we vote for Trump push forward
have him do his thing and you know avoid
Mass conflict we win yeah what's
happening on the border of Texas uh
already many many conservatives are like
don't go yeah because it is
going to be the excuse they need but I
got to tell you I'm willing to bet Soon
As Trump said deploy I bet 10,000 people
loaded up their cars and they're driving
right down
you think so and they're just going to
go be personal no I don't know they're
like I got to be there yeah oh the Pres
like my president said we need to go and
help Texas and they're not National
Guard they don't care there's a lot of
bored people unemployed people people
with nothing going on so I think we've
TR tremendous opportunity in getting
Trump elected but I do want to stress
this point what we are up against
is I mean there's there's elements of
Communism in it there's elements of
postmodernism in it but we are dealing
with a zombie culture a a a section of
us culture that sched off of the United
States and is just it's it's a it's a
death spiral EV ant and it's dangerous
if you jump inside of it they'll start
biting you but after 20 years that be
nobody left but we are inside of it cuz
they run everything we're all inside of
it but they're losing that's the point
how are they losing Disney lost a
billion dollars on its last several
movies and they're still Disney and
making the movies and but their movies
are failing it's like the the the the
the statue crumbling does not mean the
statue has crumbled if you are watching
the statue crumble don't rush over and
try and save the statue but the but the
indication here is the Avalanche hath
begun so what we need now is Donald
Trump to come in and Chuck a grenade
into the snow mound to release what's
left of the snow that's actually how
they clear Avalanches they throw
grenades into it is that cool yeah or
they Place grenades and then pull a
thing
and at it and stuff it's pretty I don't
know do they really yeah for real they
shoot canons artillery shells and stuff
I grew up in Bose Montana it was
actually really dangerous job but they
guys go up there cuz they don't handle
explosives right and it gets weird at
it's wonky at altitude like that they
cook off explosives and yeah so you
elect Donald Trump he comes in schedule
laugh fires a bunch of people forces
them out they're losing right now we
need a guy to go in there with a broom
and a dust pan that's Donald Trump uh
just clean it up yeah I I kind of
disagree on that front not that I'm
don't want Donald Trump to get in there
and blow everything up I I believe that
we must take this we must take this
thing back locally this thing must be
taken you must take back your Community
First your state first uh to think that
any one man any one man no matter who it
is George Washington you could resurrect
him today and throw him in there can
clean the rod out of DC this country
will not be saved from DC out it'll be
saved from the Hinterlands in we don't
even have our communities yet these red
States my my state why is John Corin a
senator from the state of Texas John
Corin sucks that's really question he
does suck there's no excuse for it look
and he's not the only one I don't mean
to pick on Texas they're all lindsy
Graham from maybe the reddest state in
the Union North Dakota we don't even
talk about the dtas we have all these
losers who represent these red States we
haven't even taken our red States back
yet and made them actually
anti-communist thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net censored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time